Using GPS, these trails represent pizza delivery
in Manhattan on a typical Friday night.
And is this a frog or a orse?
It's episode 52 of IMG!
This lemon looks yellow to me, and it probably
looks yellow to you as well, but not in
the same way. You see, here in this room,
this lemon is "Subtractively Yellow." It absorbs
all visible wavelengths of light except for
yellow light, which it reflects onto my retina.
But the screen that you are using to watch
this video doesn't produce yellow light at
all. In fact, it can only produce red, blue,
or green light. The really cool, but kind
of disturbing thing about this is that here
in the room, I am actually seeing "real" yellow
light. But you are seeing "fake" yellow. Absolutely
no yellow is coming off your screen and falling
onto your retina. But it still looks yellow
because it's quite easy to lie to the brain.
Our retinas contain three different types
of cone cells that are receptive to color
and each one is best suited to detect a certain
color. One is great for blue, the other is
great for green and the third is great for
red. Notice that there is no individual cell
looking for yellow. So, the way we actually
see yellow happens like this. The wavelength
of yellow light falls between the wavelengths
of red and green. And, so, when an object
reflects yellow light onto your retina, both
the green and the red cones are slightly activated,
which your brain notices and says "well, that's
what happens when something's yellow, so it
must be yellow."
All a computer monitor or a mobile phone screen
has to do to make you think you're seeing
yellow is send a little bit of red and a little
bit of green light at you. As long as the
pixels and the little subpixels on them are
small enough that you can't distinguish them
individually, your brain will just say "well,
I'm recieving some red and some green, that's
what yellow things do...hmm...it must be yellow."
Even though it actually is not...
Lemons can also produce electricity. A little
bit of zinc, a little bit of copper, and boom,
you're moving electrons around. But not that
many, I mean, the current voltage are quite
low.
You could run an LCD, but even a potato could do that...
If you wanted to run a flashlight bulb, that
would take 3,000 lemons. And if you wanted
to run a halogen bulb, well, that would take
37,000 lemons. But artist Caleb Charland
doesn't care.
He spent 11 hours hammering nails into 300
living apples hanging on trees. By connecting
them to a household lamp, he was able to make
it glow just dimly enough to capture this
image with a 4 hour exposure.
Less alive and more frightening are Steve
Shaheen's sculptures: little dudes with bulb
heads desperately trying to plug themselves in.
Merve Kahraman's "Revitalizer" never dies.
It's a lightbulb surrounded by wax. Now, the
wax melts because of the lightbulbs heat,
and drips into a special container into all
kinds of weird new shapes, but whenever you
want you can just flip it so that the new,
cooled wax is at the top.
But my favorite is the Fukusada wooden lightbulb.
It looks like a solid block of wood, but it's
actually hollow and chipped to a nearly paper-thin
width. When you turn it on you can see the
light coming from inside.
Combos.
Artist Tang Yau Hoong blew my mind this week.
We've got clear days and smoke, boats and
crocs, whales and hearts, Pie-bike, brains
and boxing gloves, day and night, but don't
be scared, you can always paint yourself some
light. Or just swing on some light.
Ok, let's frame it this way. Climbing Wall.
This fitness club in Japan uses frames and
other pretty interior elements to create a
decidedly less rugged climbing wall.
But let's get simple. Like, minimal.
Thanks to Lego, here are their bricks arranged
to represent famous characters. Enjoy.
Now for some Art Illusions.
Here's a cute couple, but can you see, in
this very same image, the baby they will soon
have? Or how about these zebras? There's
a lion hiding amongst them. Can you find it?
Billboards can be clever, but here's a great
one that makes it look like someone is pushing
out a section of the building.
But how many of you will remember seeing it?
If we assume that you don't remember experiencing
major cultural events before you're 5 or 6
years old, that means that every year there
are fewer and fewer people alive who remember
experiencing recent historical events.
xkcd made this amazing chart to show when,
in the future, the majority, more than half
of living americans, will not remember being
alive when certain things happened. For instance,
he calculated using data from the US Census
Bureau that 2012, this very year, is the
first year in American history since in which
fewer than half of living Americans remember
being alive in the 1970's.
By 2041, most of us won't remember a time
when Pluto was actually called a planet. By
2043, most of us alive won't remember living
during George W. Bush's presidency. And by
2047, more than half of living Americans
will not have been alive to have remembered
anything that you did today.
Like when you made that funny face in the
yearbook. No, no, no, THAT funny face.
If you're not following @tweetsauce, you're
missing out on daily Vsaucey content, most
of which never makes it to a video. So go
follow us on Twitter and I'm gonna leave you
with another combo. A tessellation, while you
listen to Jake Chudnow's "Flan." He made a
music video for this song over on his channel,
so check that out.
And as always,
thanks for watching.